就是关于我们，
你当了妈妈之后，
不要在孩子面前说什么我不要你了，
怎么怎么地了啊，
你不要跟着我啊，
不要说这样的话，
除了自己以身作则之外，
大家一定要警惕身边那种特别特别坏的亲戚，
那种认知特别差的亲戚，
动不动亲戚就上来挑唆，
你看你妈妈准备要二胎了，
你妈妈有了二胎了，
就不喜欢你啦，
就不要你啦，
你们家有没有这样的亲戚，
你跟你说这样的亲戚我建议给我拉黑一个，
建议给我拉黑一个，
以后别想来我家啊，
就不来往，
真的有那种认知特别差的亲戚，
老问孩子一些让孩子特别痛苦的问题，
老提一些让孩子特别恐惧的那些东西，
就是我直播间的姐妹的们，
一定要警惕这样的亲戚啊，
一定要警惕家里面的，
对家里面有一些老人，
你明明刚他说孩子吃鸡蛋是过敏的，
他非要做，
为什么他非要说让孩子吃着吃着就习惯了，
真有这样的啊，
像老人的话，
建议给我拉黑一个，
见议给我拉黑一个，
你明明说你不喜欢吃姜，
他完了之后，
他每道菜都给你，
都给你弄剁成姜碎，
剁成姜末，
每道菜都给你放吧，
我们自己女人，
尤其是当妈妈的人啊，
有了孩子之后，
你要面对这样的亲戚的时候，
也要敢于撕破脸。
啊，
敢于不来往，
敢于拉黑，
敢于说我们家不欢迎你，
下次别来了，
我现在就是这种心态，
就谁要在我孩子面前说那些挑拨离间的话，
说什么妈妈要二胎就不要你啦，
喜欢二胎，
喜欢弟弟就不喜欢你了，
喜欢妹妹就不爱你了，
别来啊，
我们家不欢迎你。